see look here de ma drayman's on LeBron
again it's like a triple switch or
something exactly what are you reading
we're studying house warriors defensive
tactics against King James it wasn't
their tactics it was their talent we
have the Tarrant
we just need smart strategy and for the
guards to finally smile on us maybe day
off tomorrow this is our chance King
James has gone from our path but he has
also gone from our excuses if we fail to
conquer these this year it could be the
end for all of us
my lord you've always believed in us we
will reward your faith I swear it I'm
afraid faith is not enough here we pay a
northern price for a blessing
the guards demand a sacrifice lord Ujiri
I pledge that I will do whatever it
takes
yes we'd give anything for the six I
know forgive me
God wake up God God Norman what are you
doin trait we're making a trade a trade
why didn't anyone tell me well you know
you did trade for a horse once and I
think the older Giri doesn't he's so
annoying
excuse me no no no I'll do it
I won't this must be some sort of
mistake he was here for a long time not
a good time what where's Lord Yu Giri
it'll all be over soon no I demand to
see lawyer Giri where is no you Giri my
lord you you can't you said you wouldn't
God's plan Drake have you all gone mad
we don't make a trade there will be no
banners here oh is that what they said
it house Tonto when they traded away
James Harden oh that's not the same
silver Lord bless this trade for it is
fair and for the good of the realm how
could you do this to your most loyal
Knights not just him also J taco hold on
o little point we know him
[Music]
all right some in the trade raptor
No
by Jacob Paul Jakob burrows please I'll
do whatever you ask for shoot more fries
Luigi Giri how could you do this she's
my best friend okay
I'll be your new best friend Josh Norman
coil
is there any other way we tried they
didn't want you please please try out
defense of shooting from anywhere
shooting survive
[Music]
hide the ball wait wait I almost forgot
we also owe them a first-round pick okay
we're good and we should be good trade
wrapped up take these Knights to the new
house hey MA and a pic and Jake puddle
my friend well whoever we're getting
back he better be a bloody monster
[Music]
dear Jennifer I'm writing to let you
know I want to playoff battle all I ask
in return is that you subscribe to
bleacher report the Lord of Light hotted
chemistry smiles upon those who are
loyal and it's cool because they can
send you Ravens when new episodes come
out